so like Marcel said my name is Carsten
and this is a project by me and a
colleague of mine biet and I and we base
it on some work from a previous
colleagues as well and there's a paper
here which describes most of the work
like there's some new stuff that I'll be
presenting but most of that is linked in
that paper so the slides will be
available afterwards if you want to look
it up alright so what we're going to
talk about is Siamese lsdm and how to
implement in the carrots and what we're
doing with those is learning a character
based face representation so let's start
with why we want to learn such a face
representation I work for a company
called Tex Colonel I have you based in
Amsterdam and part of what we do is we
do analysis on the job markets and part
of that is that we processed like
millions of vacancies and we extract job
titles so here on my left this is the
smallest text on the slides by the way
so if you can't read this in the back at
least the rest will be readable but this
is a fake see for an NLP machine
learning research engineer and we expect
this title and then you have this
extracted string but if you want to do
analytics just this thing is not very
usable because you want to count how
many people are a machine learning
researcher then you need to know that
this is also a machine learning
researcher so part of what we have is
this profession taxonomy which is like
an ontology about different types of
professions that exist and which of
those are actually the same job so for
example here you see that a machine
learning engineer and a deep learning
engineer and a machine learning
consultant are all the same profession
according to our anthology so this is
like a modeling choice how do you divide
up the job market but given this choices
that we made this ontology this taxon
that we have we have this problem of how
do we map these things that we expect
these fake C titles to those groups
those clusters in the taxonomy yeah in
this case it's a mostly manually curated
taxonomy which also means that it
doesn't have like all the variation that
you would see in like a mind taxonomy it
only has like some manually added
strings which makes premiere of this
mapping a bit harder right so what this
does taxonomy looks like in our case is
it has more than 5,000 professions and
it includes about I think twenty four
twenty five thousand job titles it
changes because people are curating it
and when we explain this problem to
people that often sounds lot like oh
that's a classification problem right
you want to classify which profession
this is however with five thousand
different professions it's very hard to
build a classifier for that so we take a
different approach also these
professions they partly overlap of them
so what do we do instead of building is
classify what we want to do is one we
want to learn the similarity between
these job phrases so that given those
job titles that we do have we can map
all the variation of job titles that we
find in extracted documents to the most
similar job titles in this taxonomy so
he so basically want to learn space in
which this distance between these job
titles is large if they are from
different professions and smaller from
the same profession and if you can meet
us there's an example PR manager and HR
manager and if you would learn like
string similarity those would be very
together because they're almost seems to
in one that the difference but in
reality they're very different jobs so
we have a baseline system which did this
which is based on string similarity with
a lot of hex to deal with these kinds of
issues but what I want to do now is
learn a representation effective
representation of these job titles such
that the space is behaved in this way
that the job titles good together quite
nicely and then you don't have this
problem it like partially overlapping
jobs in those five thousand classes
because then it's okay if you map it to
one or the other as long as they like
grouped in the space all right so that's
the problem that we're trying to solve
I'll explain a bit like what the model
is the same is BLC a model and then
we'll go to like how we implemented that
in Kerris all right so this time is PSD
M model what we're actually trying to
learn is a character level encoder so
it's a it's a we could neural network
over the characters in the string and in
the end we want to end up a bit of a
presentation that has this that has this
like semantic similarity that we're
looking for so this design a model will
output at the end some vector and the
space of those factors should be like
the space that I showed all right so who
here knows for the LST M is right who
here does not know what the LSD M is all
right so I would say most people but not
everyone so this encoder and this
encoder model let me look in here that's
easier
well it does is basically it's like
multi-layer neural network it's we could
do a new network over the cactus but
first there's a character embedding so
yeah maybe I shouldn't go too much in
detail to this the main part is this BL
cm layer that you'll see in the middle
which is a we could know network which
goes over all the characters and it goes
two ways so the BS BL s DM in the title
is bi-directional Alice TM and in the
end you get like a factor for each
character and then you calculate the
actual representation of the entire
string by averaging over all those
characters in this case and then doing
another linear transformation of that I
think for this for this presentation you
don't need to entirely understand that
you'll mostly be looking at like this
where we have this encoder and we're
just gonna show like how do you train
this as a Siamese network alright but
first like why did we choose to make
like a character level representation
well we have to deal with a lot of
spelling and in other words it's
taxonomy that we're training on is quite
small compared to variation in actual
data and we also want to work in like a
lot of different languages so we have to
deal with like different types of
morphology compound nouns so those are
words which are multiple noun stuck
together like you have in Dutch and job
titles are relatively short sequences
anyway which means that it's the
character level model is quite
applicable to this alright so we have
this
Network right I mean really get this
reputation out but how do we train it
how do you get a gradient to train on
what kind of loss can you define on this
representation in this case we decide to
do that as a service network so what you
see here is the encoder that we defined
previously and there's basically two
copies of that encoder so they both
share the weights they're at the same
model and that is the model in the end
that we are interested in because that
defines that outputs those factors that
are official stations how do we want to
train EPS
so the idea behind the siamese model is
that we take those representations on
pairs of strings and then we put another
layer on top which actually isn't like a
real layer it's just calculating cosine
distance so then we know that if we
minimize that cosine distance for
Strings which should be close together
then this reputation gets this training
signal to make space in such a way that
similar strings are close together same
thing for every simple negative examples
like here we see a Java programmer it's
not the same as the text driver so if
you know that this pair is like a
negative sample then you can maximize
this cosine distance and in our case how
do we get this training data well I show
you this taxonomy right so you can just
start generating pairs out of that
taxonomy and that way you get quite a
bit of training data because like 20,000
points not that much but all possible
pairs between those that's already a lot
more
right
all right so the question is given those
training pairs like what is the client
would label right in this case it's just
zero if they're the same pair from the
same class so just make it as small as
possible and it's one if it's from
different class so then it's just like
put them as far away as possible but
it's like small implementation detail
there that we take a margin in the loss
function that we say if you are already
far enough away then you don't get any
gradient on that all right so how do you
implement this in Karis which is despite
an depleting library
well first off why do we pick Harris
it's like a high level library so you
can make both types and quite quickly
especially for this kind of problem
because it has all these kind of layers
like LSD mi9 it's all predefined
it has we defined optimize and stuff
it's like tens flow like a nice layer on
top of tens flow or a team likes fightin
that's preference I think it's right
here
this case has this nice API and it at
the time it had like a relatively big
community compared to the other ones
currently we are a big behind already
because there's a new version of carrots
but if you want to run these examples
use this version 1.1.1 all right so
first thing right we have those two
encoders they get some inputs that input
is the characters in those inputs things
which are represented by some integer so
what you see here is this input class
which defines
input layer and the nice thing about
carrots is here you see the shape it's
just input length we don't have to
believe it the finding like what is our
batch size so it's quite a concise web
station of this and you see you defined
that the types an integer and like the
fault all the other layers will just be
floats but the first thing that we'll do
is have these characters have sensed as
integers and then look up their
embeddings yes like I said each of those
characters so the output here this
characters is a tensor of shape batch
size which we haven't defined yet by
input length now we have to define its
encoder model in this case it didn't fit
in first days to go directly entirely
into how we program that so I just a
protected it away this encoder is just
something you can give that tensor like
these inputs and you get as output
tensor these representations so this is
the encoder that we want to train in the
end so here you see the two branches of
the Siamese Network representation one
and web station to the left and the
right branch which is the encoding of
the characters so in these five lines of
code what we basically created is this
part of the network already the two
branches but they're not connected
together and again the shape of those
output tenses is than the bed size which
we didn't define by the representation
dimensionality which is the parameter on
your encoder now the trick which
basically makes this into a science
network which you can train is by just
combining those two output layers using
cosine function and then if you take the
air and the cosine function you can just
back propagate to all the previous
layers including the encoder it's
which is also a network all right so
that that basically defines the whole
Siamese network and then the outputs
shape will just be the batch size by one
because the cosine distance is just
single scalar so what you feed this is
these pairs of strings and this client
foots distance right and then carries
has the smaller class which is nightly
packages this it's a container class for
basically computation graph and you can
ask cares to now compile this graph for
you with your chosen backends we use the
ya know and future will probably be
moving to tens flow and the loss here is
mean squared error because this sort of
glosses over what I was saying before
with margin here we just take the loss
between the actual distance that this
should be big or small and the predicted
distance and then we just average that
over the batch then this time each
generator is something which will
generate these training data and these
quality distance for you and you fit on
the generator so that you basically
concludes like how to implement this in
carries so with this slide you should be
able to implement your own Simas network
so any questions on deaths that are like
short like now understand no ok cool
then we're gonna get into how do we
actually get this to work because it
turns out if you just fitted these pairs
of strings from the code table that yeah
you don't get a very low boost network
and to be fair I think this is also the
part where we ended up spending most of
our time and most of our efforts these
libraries like Harris make it very easy
to implement something like this and to
train it and to run it but in the end
it's all about like how you choose to
train it and what kind of data you
choose the model especially if you're
training on like this sort of generated
data all right so what do we actually
want this model to to be able to deal
with so if you have these extracted
titles and these like handmade nice
clean titles we wanted to be able to
deal with spelling variation and typos
like coordinator with or without a -
that's not very that doesn't have any
semantic meaning but it looks like a
different token so that's one reason why
he took a character based approach
another thing is synonyms and
abbreviations you wanted to be able to
learn that a software developer is the
same as a programmer in the software
domain but housing developer is not the
same as a housing program for example or
HR is the same as Human Resources in
most cases and because we extract these
fake C titles there will be a lot of
noise an expected title looks like
experience Java developer in London
making a lot of books an hour well these
job titles that we are trying to measure
the similarity to at least clean job
titles Java developer for example so one
way of dealing with this is data
augmentation which is the nice thing you
get from making this end-to-end model
that you can start messing with this
data easily to sort of model more the
kind of behaviors that you want
so in order to deal with noise we to
deal with typos we just add random noise
to strings and train on that to deal
with these synonyms we mine a synonym
dictionary from this code table and then
apply that to other cows so for example
if you have a manually created set you
might have C programmer but not C
developer but you will have Java
programmer and yeah Java developer and
you can just start substituting these in
and they'll be noisy but in general most
of them will be okay
or you won't find them in real data and
the other thing is that we had this PV
space I method based on stewing distance
and we have a lot of these fakes easy
process
yeah and now exactly how much but
millions per year so we can take the
ones where that model is very certain
and also use those training data and
this is actually turn out to be very
important because this data that we
generate from this code table was not
very close to how these actual strings
look right is this Java developer in
London that kind of noise so you want to
Train it to be a boost to that noise by
finding examples that look more like
real data the other problem is that if
you just simple strings from these notes
things in this way and you just sample
venom leave without any bias it will be
very unlikely that your sample negative
pair which is close enough to give you a
good hint about how to change your model
to train so the gradient will be very
low if this negative pair is already far
away so what you get is if I have this
input saying head of facilities at ei
then the neighborhood of that string
will contain head cleaning and head off
cleaning as well as facilities manager
because it never really samples these
these things which are very close in the
space already because it starts by
learning this this same string distance
but it doesn't sample them enough to
start pushing them away so one option to
do that is to just bias this sampling
towards your current neighborhood so
while you're training you can we compute
these embeddings of all these examples
and then you can sample from those which
are close by so that you can get a high
gradient if you sample something which
should be far away and you can also bias
this for positive samples which should
be close by by sampling those which are
positive but are far away it is doing
space for example if you have here this
negative neighbors you have Business
Economics teacher and without the
without a local sampling you have
something like business engineer because
there's a string off lab it will be
close by and now with this neighbor
sampling it you will have a very high
probability of sampling these sort of
imposter codes called some instincts
another thing horticulturalist and hotel
receptionist like these post fixes this
dis network starts learning these post
fixes pretty rapidly and that might
confuse it as well but then if you
sample again from this local
neighborhood space you can train it to
move away from these pathological kind
of behaviors and you can also simple
positive neighbors so that you can make
sure that if you just sample negative
neighbors you might just start
increasing the space because you're
sampling in such a way that you're
saying like all these things should be
far away but you also want to put in
some constraints about which things
which should they keep clothes
so that it like goes in a corrector
action mmm right so given this Simas
training and this data augmentation how
do we get results and how do we actually
measure these results so one way of
measuring is just you take some
prediction set and you take some
thousand jobs and you start labeling if
the correct code the correct profession
was predicted or not and what you see
here on the left are three different
models or a baseline model which was
already quite good and then our Siamese
baseline which was the model that we
sort of presented here and then this
time is based on closest neighbor
sampling I see that the Siamese baseline
already improves over this baseline
model and then adding neighbor sampling
we get like quite a nice improvement
however we also still want to know like
those behaviors that we said that we
want to model those invariants to noise
the invariance the typos synonyms how do
you measure this well a good way that we
found for measuring this kind of
behavior is by sort of making machine
learning unit tests so basically you
just create specific data sets but these
things where you know that this model
showed is behavior or for example for
the typo you just make a data set with
strings which are actually the same
string but have a typo and then you
measure how well doesn't that so that's
a very cheap way to start if you know
some of these pathological modes or some
of these behaviors that you want to
model it's a very cheap way of starting
to dig into that and to debug your model
that way
so those are the three columns on the
left the typos are the steps
compensation is synonymy does it learn
to recognize synonyms and the acts of
words is this invariance to all this
noise in this extracted data and what we
see is that this trigrams based language
is basically a variant of string
distance it's very good with the typos
but it doesn't learn about synonyms
because it can't learn that developer
and program are the same thing and our
Sammis model especially with the
neighbor sampling start to really pick
up on these synonyms now on this except
where it's noise the baseline was used
as a model to select these extra words
examples so we couldn't measure that
because that would be like perfect score
always but we can distinguish now
between different versions of model
which was very important than developing
this model and like deciding where
should you focus your rdf for next some
examples of that on the top is what does
this model learn to do better than the
baseline it's this mutable from the back
yeah so it off I see I see some hands
Karen ladies
so if we have a font office executive as
a string the string distance method will
pick up something like finance executive
well this encoder model will find that
coordinator is basically the same as
executive and front office coordinators
actually not close in front office
executive then finance executive same
for the clinical administration system
again a lot of string overlap but here
this model learns that medical and
clinical are very related even though
it's just on a character level so you
are quite happy with that kind of
results
on the other hand some stuff like a
state HC branch manager you still see
some of this pathological behavior which
also has a lot of to do with like which
data do you feel it
Maya's vision is how more reveal data
you have how less of these kind of
errors you'll see all right so to
conclude we can learn an encode model
that encodes semantics of job titles
better than this trichome distance even
if you try very hard to manually create
all these different job titles and we
can train it as a Siamese model so you
can you only have to give it is it far
or close despair instead of having to
like give some quantity for the web
station or a gift like a lot of data to
learn an embedding and careful sampling
of this data to train it really improves
performance as well as taking into like
these different error types that you see
right so we attack Sakana we are hiring
as well